le kit et salariale est toujours bien
loin d'être une réalité au canada un
sondage léger pour la firme adp canada
révèle qu'en 2019 les hommes avec un
salaire moyen de près de soixante mille
dollars ces seize mille dollars de plus
que les femmes déclarent de 24%
une situation qui s'améliore en
apparence parce que l'écart dépasse les
25% un an plus tôt mais adp souligne que
ces données écarte la rémunération
supplémentaire comme les primes la
participation aux bénéfices ou le compte
de dépenses les hommes reçoivent deux
fois plus que les femmes soient ses 1600
$ de plus dans leurs poches l'an dernier
et femmes sont toujours plus nombreuses
à travailler à temps partiel ou le
salaire minimum
elles sont également trois fois plus
nombreuses que les hommes à mettre leur
carrière sur pause pour prendre un congé
parental
[Musique]